monsieur le ministre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de cette commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier nos
travaux portent sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuel et racial et les
problématiques liées à la gouvernance
financière des organismes de gouvernance
du monde sportif monsieur le ministre
vous avez commencé votre carrière au
sein de l'Union athlétique gayacoise
club de rugby à 15 puis rejoignez le
Club Athlétique bordeaubg le Gironde
vous mettez fin à votre carrière de
joueur en 1991 puis devenez entraîneur
du Stade bordelay puis du Stade Français
vous êtes sélectionneur du 15 de France
de 1999 à 2007 puis secrétaire d'État
chargé des sports du 22 octobre 2000
2007 au 23 juin 2009 sous le
gouvernement Fillon 2 vous êtes élu
président de la FFR le 3 décembre 2016
le 13 août 2017 le JDD indique que vous
seriez intervenu auprès de jean-diel
Simonet qui préside la commission
d'appel de la FFR afin que cette
commission examine avec je cite
bienveillance plusieurs décision de la
Commission discipline de la Ligue
nationale de rugby au sein du club
Montpel h rugby le club est présidé par
Mohamed Altrad un homme d'affaires milli
milliardaire à la tête du groupe
alttrade entreprise spécialisée dans le
BTP or monsieur altrade est en relation
d'affaires avec vous le 30 août 2017 la
ministre des Sports annonce l'ouverture
d'une enquête confiée à à l'igjs sur les
pressions présumées exercé par Monsieur
la porte à l'encontre de la commission
d'appel le 4 décembre 2017 le rapport de
mission est transmis au parquet en
application de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale conformément à la
recommandation formulée par les deux
inspecteurs généraux le 13 décembre 2022
vous et Mohammed Altrad
est moed pardon alttrade est tous deux
condamnés par le tribunal correctionnel
de Paris vous êtes condamné pour
corruption et trafic d'influence à 2 ans
de prison avec sursis et 75000 € B
amende pour avoir rendu une série
d'arbitrage au bénéfice du groupe
alttrad dont l'octroit du sponsoring
maillot du 15 de France la présidente du
tribunal a justifié la condamnation par
je cite gravité des faits et la
méconnaissance des principes de
déontologie que vous aviez la
responsabilité d'appliquer le tribunal a
notamment noté que la procédure de mise
en concurrence a été conduite afin que
seul la société A altrade formule une
proposition vous êtes également reconnu
coupable d'avoir favorisé à plusieurs
reprises le
MH propriété de moed alttrade notamment
en intervenant pour alléger la sanction
disciplinaire
suspensionnée monsieur altrade est
condamné à 18 mois de prison avec
sursis la présidente du tribunal
correctionnel de Paris avait également
prononcé une peine complémentaire d'
d'interdiction la fonction de président
de FFR pour une durée de 2 ans qui ne
sera finalement pas exécutée monsieur la
porte ayant fait appel monsieur la porte
démissionne cependant de sa fonction de
vice-président de World rugby à ce stade
votre condamnation n'a pas été confirmée
en appel vous êtes donc toujours présumé
innocent la ministre des Sports madame
Amélie oua casterin juge que cette
condamnation fait obstacle à la
poursuite de votre mandat le comité
d'éthique de la FFR vous demande de vous
mettre en retrait ce que vous faites en
désignant un président délégué le 6
janvier 2023 Monsieur Patrick Buisson le
27 janvier sur demande du bureau fédéral
vous démissionnez de votre fonction de
président de FFR le 19 novembre 2023 le
président du Montpellier Hero rugby donc
monsieur Mohed altrade vous nomme
directeur du rugby du club monsieur nous
ne sommes pas là pour vous nous
substituer à la justice dans cette
affaire mais pour essayer d'identifier
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements dans la
gouvernance des fédérations et les
contrôles qui s'appliquent à elle vous
avez été secrétaire d'État au sport et
donc chargé de la tutelle des fédération
dans un bref propô liiminaire
pouvez-vous tout d'abord nous dire quels
sont les faits dont vous avez eu
connaissance dans le champ de cette
commission lorsque vous étiez secrétaire
d'État et les réponses que vous y avez
apporté
qu'avez-vous mis en œuvre en tant que
secrétaire d'État au sport sur les
différents axes de travail de cette
commission lutte contre les VSS les
discriminations le racisme renforcement
de l'éthique et de la probité du monde
sportif je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendu par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre micro je le
jure je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole non merci
beaucoup madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteuse mesdames Messieurs les les
les députés
euh votre première question c'est est-ce
que en tant que secrétaire d'État j'ai
été euh soumis
mis des actes de racisme oui une fois
c'était un joueur de Valencienne un
joueur de football de Valencienne
effectivement qui
avait envers lequel on avait tenu un
joueur adverse avait tenu des propos des
propos raciste je m'étais moi-même
déplacé dans son chez lui à valencien
dans son dans dans sa maison pour
discuter avec lui pour essayer d'abord
de le réconforter parce que c'est vrai
que je sentais qu'il était très très
très touché très très
affecté mais j'ai pas venir vous savez
ça fait 15 ansin donc sincèrement des
choses de mise en place celle qui exitit
ou celle qu'on a
développé j'ai moins souvenir je peux
vous parler par contre de ce que nous
avons fait nous au sein de la Fédération
française de rugby maintenant ou
ultérieurement quand vous le
souhaiterez alors par contre dans la
question il était noté VSS
discrimination racisme renforcement de
l'éthique et de la probité du monde
sportif oui mais je vous dis sur 2 ans
de de de de de secrétaire d'État au
sport un peu moins de 2 ans
la la la chose qui m'avait le plus
heurté effectivement c'était cette cette
cet acte de racisme envers ce joueur de
envers ce joueur de football à moins que
que j'oublie d'autres phases et si vous
en avez dites-moi les je me rémémerai
mais j'ai pas souvenir il y a II on
avait eu un une problématique
avec pareil avec lormanodou qui avait
été attaqué par son ancien compagnon sur
la sur la grille de départ qui était
venu la menacer et cetera mais bon euh
c'était des j'ai envie de dire des des
cas à résoudre mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours c'est aussi de la comment
dirais-je de la violence puisque c'est
de la violence verbale quoi c'est donc
elle l'attaquit pour qu'elle soit moins
performante et donc on avait on l'avait
reçu avec monsieur le Président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozi de l'époque
et on on é intervenu auprès du du du du
CONI donc le Comité olympique italien
pour dire que Ben ce qui s'était passé
et qu'il prennent les mesures
nécessaires pour que ça ne se reproduise
pas donc vous confirmez qu'en dehors de
ces faits vous n'avez jamais été
confronté lors de de votre mandat de
secrétaire d'État au sport à à à
d'autres affaires relatives à ces à ces
différents sujets et si vous peut-être
que j'en oublie he mais de mémoire j'en
ai pas j'en ai pas
d'autres ah pardon de mon côté à moi
merci merci beaucoup
euh peut-être la question euh ça serait
aussi de se dire à l'époque où vous
étiez secrétaire d'État est-ce que vous
aviez des remontées ou des alertes sur
euh euh dans ce mouvement sportif et au
sein de ces fédérations de phénomènes de
violence sexuelle et sexiste est-ce que
c'était des axes de travail des pistes
d'alertes qui était déjà identifié à
l'époque au sein du ministère où
vraiment ces affaires explosent j'ai
envie de dire presque au moment où Sarah
abbol prend la parole par le biais de
son
livre pour vous dire la vérité j'ai pas
souvenir ça fait 15 ans ce qui est sûr
c'est que la prise de parole de Sarah
beitball a déclenché beaucoup de choses
ça c'est une certitude elle a euh elle a
fait en sorte que les choses avancent de
façon de de de façon rapide oui ça c'est
une c'est une certitude après comme je
vous le dis moi j'ai pas j'ai j'ai j'ai
pas souvenir mes prédécesseurs
travaillaient aussi sur les sur les
questions hein je dis pas qu'on est
parti d'une page d'une page blanche bon
donc je je je me rappelle pas qu'on ait
amélioré la loi ou amélioré des choses
pour que que ça aille comme on l'a fait
par exemple
à la présidence de la Fédération
française de rugby mais bon il y avait
beaucoup moins de cas beaucoup moins de
gens parlai on était pas dans on éétait
pas dans la même sphère et vous l'avez
dit à juste titre la prise de parole de
Sarah bball a été un élément
déclencheur et donc au niveau de la
gestion par les fédérations est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous étiez justement peut-être
qu'il y avait une réflexion sur la
relation entre le ministère de tutelle
et ses fédérations pour avancer sur
certains axes de travail qui peuvent
être de tout ça soit la probité le
racisme les discriminations au sein de
ce mouvement sportif il y a toujours eu
des des des des comment dirais-je des
des des bon des bons fonctionnements
mais on n'est pas allé plus loin que ce
qui existait non ça c'est c'est
non mais je je le répète à l'époque il y
avait très très peu de cas hein on était
très personne nous faisait
remonter de choses ici et là c'est c'est
bien après que c'est que que que que les
choses ont entre guillemets éclaté et
que les les voies se sont libérées c'est
une bonne
ch alors pas forcément des
cas confirmé mais est-ce queil y avait
des bruits des des choses qui se
disaient dans ce mouvement sportif je
pense à la FFT par exemple à
l'époque voilà est-ce que à ce moment-là
peut-être vous avez eu l'idée de pousser
plus loin la réflexion en tout cas les
investigations sur le
sujet non sincèrement moi j'avais pas
pas de bruit qui me revenait concernant
des actes de
violence encore une fois j'i pas j'en ai
vraiment pas souvenir que ce soit la FFT
vous allez me parler peut-être de la
Fédération Française de patinage où
après des choses sont ont été dites sont
sorties mais nous à l'époque c'était
l'omer personne personne n faisait
remonter quoi que quoi que ce soit quoi
et à la Fédération françise de tennis je
sais pas ce que vous voulez évoquer mais
moi vraiment là j'ai pas
de j'ai pas d'exemple en tête quoi
par exemple sur le patinage artistique
vous dites sur le sur le sport de glace
vous dites après les choses ont été
dites mais est-ce qu'à l'époque il y
avait déjà des des choses qui
circulaient justement dans ce dans au
sein de cette fédération en tout cas au
niveau des athlètes pas ma connaissance
c'est ce que je vous
dis vous aviez évoqué en 2008 l'idée de
faire payer les clubs sur la question du
racisme est-ce que peut-être vous pouvez
revenir là-dessus sur cette prop que
vous aviez
faite non c'était une manière de
responsabiliser les clubs effectivement
parce que si eux les premiers ne gèrent
pas ces problématiques c'est très
difficile nous depuis le ministère des
sport à
Paris de s'en préoccuper c'est pour ces
raisons là que la Fédération Française
de Rubby ensite on a décentralisé
permettez-moi l'expression parce que ça
part d'en bas si en bas les gens ne sont
pas ne sont pas concernés d'abord ne
sont pas formés parce que c'est pas
c'est pas simple donc il faut il faut
les former il faut faire en sorte qu'il
que que les victimes puissent prévenir
et donc c'était dans ce sens
certainement encore une fois il y a 15
ans mais c'était dans ce sens je voulais
je voulais je voulais dire au club c'est
vous les premiers responsables c'est à
vous de
gérer ces ces problèmes
là alors juste peut-être en 2009 le
président de la FFT a été condamné pour
prise illégale d'intérêt
euh pour avoir cumulé des emplois
salarié à la FFT et à TF1 maison maire
d'Eurosport qui retransmettait les
matchs de tennis donc justement suite à
cette affaire est-ce qu'il y a pas eu
des
2009 quand le premier semestre 2è
semestre moi je suis parti au mois de au
début juin
2009 oui alors oui juste titre euh en
fait il a été condamné à ce moment-là
donc ça dire que l'affaire était connue
certainement avant puisqu'il y a dû
avoir un procès pour qu'il soit condamné
donc est-ce que cette question
justement de la prise illégale d'intérêt
de de cette probité finalement au sein
des fédérations c'est pas un sujet sur
lequel vous vous êtes penché à ce
moment-là juillet 2009 pour la
condamnation juillet 2009 oui c'est ça
donc moi je suis parti début juillet
mais fait peu importe donc si vous dites
que qu'il été condamné c'est que
l'affaire était était en
cours je m'en rappelle vaguement
maintenant que vous que vous me
l'évoquez mais on a on je je je suppose
qu'on a dû attendre la la condamnation
définitive fait la condamnation ben
comme dans mon cas hein personnel quoi
on par pas avant d'être avant d'être
condamné donc euh euh j'ai j'ai j'ai pas
un grand souvenir de de de de de cela
non donc au moment où le procès s'ouvre
sur cette sur cette affaire de prise
illégale d'intérêt il y a pas de sujet
qui se pose à vous au niveau du
ministère pour justement peut-être aller
regarder envisager des contrôles du
ministère sur les fédérations pour sur
cette question notamment de la probité
au sein du mouvement sportif j'ai pas
souvenir non qu' soit qu'on ait euh
qu'on a mis qu'on a mis des choses en
place ça me ça me ça me dit rien je je
répète je pense qu'on devait attendre
certainement la condamnation ou pas du
président de la Fédération de
tennis
le mois dernier vous nous avions demandé
à Monsieur éic Borghini membre du comité
exécutif de la Fédération Française de
foot s'il comprenait que la nomination
de Noël legrette à la tête du bureau
parisien de la FIFA a pu choquer
l'opinion publique et re perçu comme un
signe d'impunité nous lui avions demandé
si cette nomination était de nature à
donner une bonne image du football
français nous vous posons la même
question pensez-vous que la nomination
comme directeur du rugby d'un club d'un
homme condamné en première instance pour
corruption trafic d'influence et trafic
d'intérêt soit de nature à donner une
bonne image de rugby vous avez déclaré
mon retour à Gace les con mais des cons
il y en a partout et cela ne m'intéresse
pas reprendriez-vous ces propos devant
la commission d'enquête
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de
mal la loi me permet vous comprenez bien
que quand je me suis engagé j'ai tout
fait de mon côté avec mes avocats
monsieur alttrade avec ses avocats pour
bien contrôler faire en sorte que ce
soit possible j'ais pas un contrat puis
demain on me dit c'est ce n'est plus
possible donc c'est c'est dans ce dans
ce dans ce principe là qu'on a respecté
encore une fois la légalité et et que
donc effectivement il y a toujours des
gens qui sont ben jaloux aigris mais
cela ne m'intéresse pas voilà j'ai
qu'une vie et j'ai surtout pas envie de
passer ma vie à dire à ceux qui critique
en permanence qu'ils ont raison ou
qu'ils ont tort si je n'avais pas pu
exercer cette fonction ne l'aurait pas
fait voilà à partir du moment où rien ne
me l'aempêché j'ai accepté ce challenge
jusqu'au mois de juin pour aider ce club
à qui est effectivement dans la
difficulté donc vous ne pensez pas que
ça puisse nuire à l'image du sport mais
je vois pas comment ça peut ça peut
nuire à l'image du sport fait je suis
présumé prés présumé innocent je vois
pas en quoi ça peut nu ça veut dire quoi
il faut plus il faudrait plus rien faire
il faudrait rester à la maison et plus
rien
faire
euh du coup en partant de ce principe là
est-ce que vous estimez que vous auriez
pu ou dû rester à la tête de la
Fédération française de
rugby mais j'aurais pu y rester puisque
je suis présomé innocent j'ai j'ai j'ai
démissionné pour des raisons
personnelles mais bien sûr que j'aurais
pu y rester jusqu'à ben jusqu'à ce que
la condamnation soit définitive ou pas
oui ça me SEM ou alors la présentation
n'existe plus je je
je en août 2017 donc puisque madame la
Présidente vous avez posé la question
dans son propos introductif le JDD
révèle que vous seriez intervenu auprès
de jean-dianiel Simonet président de la
commission d'appel de la FFR afin que
cette commission examine avec
bienveillance plusieurs décisions de la
commission de discipline de la Ligue
nationale de rugby au sujet du club
Montpellier héros rugby la mon l'amende
prononcée contre le club avait été
ramené le lendemain de votre
intervention de 70000 € à 20000 €
d'amende votre société BL communication
avait signé le 19 février 2017 un
contrat de droit à l'image avec altra
d'investissement Autority en tant que
président de la FFR et vous appartenait
de veiller à l'application du règlement
disciplinaire qui prévoit que les
membres des organs
disciplinaires se prononcent en toute
indépendance et ne peuvent recevoir
d'instruction concevez-vous qu'un tel
appel téléphonique au vu de vos
relations d'affaires avec la société
Haen puisse être considéré comme
relevant du trafic d'influence vous me
permettrez de pas répondre à ces
questions il il y a une instruction qui
est en cours je crois que vous avez reçu
un mail de mon avocat c'est pas que je
va pas y répondre et j'ai a répondu au
tribunal donc il y a pas il y a rien à
cacher mais je ne vais pas interférer
sur
une sur sur une une procédure en cours
alors euh dans ce cas comment est-ce que
comment est-ce que les règlements
disciplinaires étaient appliqués et qui
les faisait respecter au sein de la fait
faire le secrétaire général est en
charge de tout ce qui est
règlement règlement intérieur règlement
disciplinaire c'est le secrétaire
général qui a qui a la charge de la
Fédération Française de Ruby de tout
cela donc vous vous ne regardiez pas du
tout comment se passait en fait le
contrôle de ce point de vue- là vous
aviez vous aviez peut-être des points
des vous savez j'étais un président
bénévole moi je donnais des grands axes
et des lignes politiques et ensuite
c'est les élus d'accord les élus et bien
sûr les les salariés de la Fédération
Française de Rugby qui mettaient en en
place tout ce que nous décidions donc
moi encore une fois j'étais là d'abord
pour faire de la représentation parce
que président de fédération c'est
beaucoup de représentation et j'avais
deux chantiers très très importants
c'était redonner vie un petit peu à
toutes nos équipes de France pour une
simple et bonne raison c'est que et
notamment notre équipe de France
masculine c'est c'est c'est sans elle il
y a pas de il y a pas de il y a pas de
budget à la Fédération 85 % des recettes
de notre fédération française de rugby
c'est notre équipe masculine elle était
8e à l'époque je vous rappelle donc je
peux vous garantir que ma principale
préoccupation au départ c'était de
redonner encore une fois de la force à
notre équipe de France pour qu'elle
redevienne moteur et moteur ça veut dire
des partenaires qui veulent
l'accompagner et donc avoir un maximum
de de gens qui accompagnent la
fédération pour développer le monde
amateur parce que c'est ceci ceci est
quand même assez assez cocasse c'est que
c'est une équipe de une équipe de France
qui a 85 % du 85 % des recettes fait
vivre le monde amateur donc c'est pour
ces raisonsl qu'encore une fois ma
préoccupation chacun avait bien
euh des tâches définies et le secrétaire
général Christian Dulin avait encore une
fois en charge tout ce qui est la
réglementation interne de la
fédération et et du coup comment était
garanti l'indépendance des commissions
internes de la FFR par lui par le
secrétaire général mais nous nous en
discutions quand même tout le monde
était au courant he c'était pas
c'était pas il y a pas d'omerta là
chaque fois qu'il prenait la parole il
évoquait les règlements et cetera et
cetera donc tout le monde était au
courant s'agissant du contrat de
partenariat maillot comme je vous le
comme je vous l'indiquais dans les
propos liminires signant entre la FFR et
la société AA nous souhaiterions que
vous réagissiez au propos tenu par
Monsieur Laurent gabanini directeur
général de FFR selon monsieur gabanini
le contrat de partenariat a été réputé
et jugé comme conforme et au juste prix
ce contrat n'a absolument pas été remis
en question dans le cadre de ce procès
donc la fédération ne pouvait pas
remettre en cause ce contrat puisqu'il a
été fait en totale conformité dans les
règles du droit et de la concurrence et
au juste prix or un extrait du jugement
avait largement circulé dans la presse
notamment celui-ci la procédure de mise
en concurrence a été réduite
afin que seulle la la société Aya
formule une proposition la procédure de
mise en concurrence du contrat de
sponsoring maot et sa conclusion
ont-elles été mises en cause au cours du
procès sincèrement je je vous ai dit je
je veux pas parler d'une chose don la
procédure est en cour donc je ne
parlerai pas de cette histoire là les
choses sont
claires alors là pour le coup on vous
demande pas de réagir par rapport à
l'appel qui a été fait c'est juste sur
le jugement qui a était qui lui a été
prononcé et sur les propos qui ont été
tenus par Monsieur gabanini
euh alors même que un extrait du
jugement a été largement révélé dans les
médias donc est-ce que vous nous
confirmez euh juste est-ce que vous
enfin voilà est-ce que vous nous
confirmez que ce qui a été déclaré dans
le jugement qui a été prononcé et bien
la procédure de mise en concurrence a
été conduite afin que seul la société
Aya formule une proposition c'est ce que
j'ai d au procet c'est faux on a fait
les choses comme il comme comme il
fallait c'est bien pour ça que nous
contestons j'entends que vous disiez que
c'est faux mais ce que je vous demande
c'est est-ce que c'est ce qui a été
rendu dans le jugement non dans le dans
le dans le rendu du jugement il y a que
la
valeur la valeur du sponsoring maillot
était logique voilà ça c'est clair tout
le monde dit c'était le prix du marché
ça ça a été
dit vous savez quand on a signé ce quand
on a signé ce partenariat nous étions
entre la 6e et la 8e place c'est sûr que
c'est plus la même c'est plus la même
chose aujourd'hui où notre équipe de
France malgré sa défaite sur le quart de
finale à 80 % de victoire en 4 ans est
redevenu l'une des quatre meilleures
équipes du monde c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est plus c'est
certainement plus le même le le même
prix mais à l'époque croyez-moi personne
ne voulait être partenaire de l'équipe
de France de rugby enfin quand je dis
partenaire partenaire maillot il y avait
heureusement des partenaires à la
Fédération donc vous nous dites grosso
modo que cette phrase n'est pas dans le
jugement la procédure de mise en
concurrence a été conduite afin que seul
la société Aya formule une proposition
et que ça il soit je vous dis pas que ça
que ça n'y est pas mais ce que je peux
vous garantir c'est que nous nous
contestons ça j'entends que vous le
contestiez il y a il y a aucun souci
sauf que nous en fait monsieur gabanini
nous dit que ce n'est pas dans le
jugement donc c'est pour ça qu'on vous
pose la question est-ce que cette phrase
fait bien partie du jugement qui a été
rendu en première instance et je vous je
vous le répondrai un fait de matiné
vous pourrez nous transmettre le
jugement euh alors pouvez-vous revenir
sur les conditions de passation en 2018
de ce contrat de partenariat comment en
tant que président de la FR avez-vous
veillé à la bonne application des règles
de concurrence de transparence et de
publicité de la procédure l'ensemble des
partenaires majeurs de la FFR ont-ils
été consultés dans de bonnes conditions
et en même temps temps sans qu'une
société soit consultée en premier
sincèrement je vous ai dit que je
répondrai pas à ces questions je n'y
répondrai pas mais j'ai a déjà répondu
je veux dire vous faites un double
travail vous allez vous allez auprès du
Tribunal ils vont vous dire les réponses
que nous avons
donné alors peut-être pas sur ce contrat
spécifiquement mais de manière générale
quand il y avait des contrats qui sont
qui étaient passés comment est-ce que
vous veillez à la bonne application des
règles de concurrence et de transparence
d'abord la Fédération française de rugby
n'a pas de pouvoirjudicateur on n pas
obligé de faire appppelledof d'accord
nous on en a on en a fait un concernant
le le sponsoring maillot parce que
c'était c'est unique un sponsor maillot
il y a beaucoup de partenaires mais des
partenaires maillot il y en a qu'un je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il va y en avoir
trois parce que je crois qu'ils en
mettent un sur le dos et et un sur le
short mais à l'époque il y en avait
qu'un donc c'était unique c'est pour ces
raisaul qu'on avait fait un appel
d'offre voilà après vous savez euh il y
a malheureusement pour nous pas plor de
partenaires qui se disputent qui se dis
la place un partenaire qui vient nous
voir si je prends le cas de de casino
qui est l'un des derniers que j'ai que
que que que j'ai traité d'abord c'est
c'est notre cellule commerciale qui
s'est qui s'est qui s'est chargé de
développer tout ça et quand un
partenaire veut nous accompagner bien
sûr que le président va les rencontrer
discuteter avec eux voilà et on est
toujours ravi qu'un partenaire veuille
nous accompagner parce qu'encore une
fois c'est pas pour payer le monde
professionnel c'est pour accompagner le
monde amateur et faire tout ce qu'on a
fait derrière et déployer pour le monde
amateur mais s'il y a pas de moyen
financier vous déployez
rien alors justement peut-être pour nous
expliquer comment ça se passe quand on
décide de faire un partenariat euh
comment ça se passe si on fait pas
d'appel d'offre comment les les choses
se mettent en place on enlève l'appel
d'offre maillot d'accord oui ouii en
général
bon donc je vous prends le cas de casino
voilà nous on a j'en étais le premier
j'avais comme tout le monde son réseau
donc j'essayais d'aller voir des
entreprises est-ce qu'elles veulent nous
accompagner être être partenaire de la
fédération et cetera des fois c'est oui
des fois c'est non et cetera et puis on
a quand même heureusement une cellule
commerciale à la fédération qui
travaille bien et pour le cas par
exemple de casino que je vous dis un
jour ils m'ont dit tiens casino est
intéressé pour être partenaire de la
Fédération Française de Rugby à hauteur
de temps il souhaitent ça ça ça et donc
j'ai rencontré la dame en question qui
s'occupait de la communication de de
casino bon on a évoqué euh sa volonté de
nous accompagner bien sûr nous ravi que
qu'elle nous accompagne et et donc ça se
fait comme ça c'est aussi simple que ça
aujourd'hui on a euh si gros partenaires
il compris le le le sponsoring maillot
qui sont les partenaires majeurs je
dirais et derrière on a tout un tas de
partenaires et là il y a pas d'appel d'
vienent qui veut j'ai envie de dire et
plus ils seront nombreux mieux nous nous
porterons et à l'époque quand vous étiez
enfin à l'époque quand vous étiez le
président de la Fédération vous étiez
sur un un budget de combien la
Fédération moi quand je suis arrivé le
budget était de 106 millions à la
Fédération quand je suis parti il était
de 133 de
mémoire et vos partenariats à l'aide
d'un montant
euh autour de jusqu'à
grosso modo ce qu'on appelle le socle
commun pour les partenaires majeurs est
de 3 millions de plus tout ceux qu'il
active ça c'est c'est les six
partenaires majeurs euh après ça ça va
de de de ça peut aller de 300000 200000
à à 1 million et demi ça dépend il y a
pas de il y a pas de il il y a surtout
les six partenaires officiels et et
derrière il y a d'autres partenaires
mais plus il P plus il demande de place
d'activation ce qui est tout à fait
logique donc en retour dans le pack
partenariat ce sont quoi ce sont des
places des places des Loges ouai il y a
de tout voilà il y a de tout 3 mli2
c'est le S c'est du partenariat ou du
sponsoring pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
du partenariat je préfère le terme
partenariat à sponsoring moi même même
si c'est les deux puisque puisquon les
voit ils sont visibles oui certains plus
que d'autres même si c'est pas la même
chose chose oui mais bon pour moi c'est
c'est partenariat et sponsoring moi je
j'aime j'aime beaucoup le terme
partenariat pourquoi parce que ça montre
une certaine fidélité on est partenaire
nous accompagne et on a la chance à la
Fédération d'avoir des partenaires
ancestraux j'ai envie de dire qui nous
accompagnent depuis plus de 30 ans la
GMF la Société Générale orange un peu
moins mais est un partenaire fidèle et
donc on est on est fier de on on est
fier de tout ça donc pour moi c'est
partenaires et sponsoring et je vous le
dis les six partenaires majeurs le socle
alors peut-être que ça a évolué
maintenant hein moi ça fait près d'un an
que je suis parti mais le sole était le
3 million2 plus euh tout ce qu'ils
activaient et qui coûtait bien sûr de de
l'argent dans les 3 mlions 2 il y a déjà
des places he je vous rassure
hein en septembre 2022 la FFR a recruté
un directeur de contrôle de gestion qui
a lancé un audit des achats pouvez-vous
nous exposer les raisons pour lesquelles
vous avez souhaité effectuer cet audit
des dysfonctionnements liés au processus
achat de la FFR avait-il été constaté on
a eu on a eu un contrôle
àa de la FAA pardon je sais plus très
bien si c'était 2020 ou 2021 j'ai plus
en tête il nous avait donné certaines
préconisations et en fonction de ses
préconisation effectivement notre
directeur général Laurent gabini a fait
en sorte d'aller dans le sens des
préconisations de la FA et donc de
nommer un directeur pour tout ce qui est
contrôle des achats et
autes
et du coup quels ont été les les
résultats de cet audit justement que
vous avez euh ben peut-être peut-être
qu'il est arrivé après moi moi je suis
parti 3 mois après
hein j'ai envie de dire l'audit avait
été fait par la FA hein qui nous donnait
des préconisations vous devez faire ça
vous devez faire ça vous devez faire ça
devz faire ça vous SAVE vous savez je
répondis à toutes vos questions nous des
contrôles on en a eu en permanence que
je sache on a toujours eu de très très
bons retours notamment sur le dernier où
je n'étais plus là puisque c'était je
crois mars avril mai où l'Inspection
Générale a fait pendant 3 mois a vécu à
la Fédération française de rugby a tout
regardé je crois que ils n'ont pas le
rendu écrit mais oralement je crois
qu'ils ont eu je dirais pas les
satisfait parce que ce serait
prétentieux
mais ils leur ont dit que tout ça était
bien contrôlé et bien géré et j'ai une
totale à Laurent gabanini qui est un
directeur général
extraordinaire en juin 2022 le tribunal
administratif de Versailles saisi par
des dirigeants d'un club varois avait
jugé illégal le refus de la FFR de
communiquer des contints des documents
comptables la FR ne s'était pas conformé
à la décision de la CADA ce qui avait
contraint les dirigeants du club Barois
à porter l'affaire devant la justice
administrative Floriant grill donc
l'actuel président de la FFR nous a
formé en audition avoir demandé à ce
qu'une suite positive soit donnée à ce
type de demande dans un souci de
transparence financière ce qui constitue
un changement de doctrine par rapport à
votre présidence pourquoi avoir refusé
la transparence financière vis-à-vis des
clubs de
rugby déjà c'est pas des clubs de rugby
c'est des ligues professionnelles c'est
pas des clubs de rugby c'est c'est des
ligues euh mais mais c'est faux nous
tout est transparent vous savez la
Fédération Française de Rugby euh les
ligues doivent faire remonter leur bilan
annuel leur bilan financier leur rapport
moraux et cetera et cetera donc tout
tout remonte à la Fédération et tout est
contrôlé je crois que ce qui s'est passé
dans le dans dans la Ligue PACA parce
que c'est c'est ça vous parlez vous
dites le Var mais c'est pas le Var c'est
la Ligue PACA et ce qui s'est passé dans
la ligue la Ligue PACA était sur ce que
j'ai bien compris des affaires internes
où des gens n'arrêtez pas de les de les
harceler des gens sous l'influence de
Monsieur apparemment hein de les harcelé
pour telle ou telle telle raison mais
encore une fois les comptes de chaque
ligue chaque année remontent à la
Fédération française de rugby tout est
transparent et ça a toujours existé
c'est pas moi qui l'ai mis en place ça a
toujours
existé alors on entend sauf que là quand
même c'est le c'est une décision du
tribunal administratif qui dit que c'est
que que lorsqu'ils ont été saisis par
les dirigeants ils ont jugé illégal le
refus de la FFR de communiquer les
documents donc ça veut bien dire qu'il y
avait quand même un problème puisque y
compris le tribunal a tranché cette
question qu' les ont transmis
après une fois qu'il y a eu la nouvelle
présidence monsieur gris il a demandé à
ce qu'une suite favorable soit donnée à
cette affaire à cette demande donc il a
demandé à ce que les documents soient
transmis mais jusqu'à son arrivée ce
n'était pas le cas malgré qu'il y ait eu
une décision du tribunal
ouais peut-être si vous le dites je pas
j'ai pas je je me rappelle un petit peu
de cette de de cette problème
problématique mais mais nous on avait
les comptes nous on savait que tout
était légal on savait que tout était
était été transparent et puis s'ils ont
été transmis tant mieux donc je veux
dire je m'aperçois que s'ils ont été
transmis rien n'a été j'ai pas entendu
dire qu'il y avait des choses illégales
au CH de la Ligue
PACA la question c'est pas tellement de
savoir si les comptes étaient illégals
ou s'il y avait un problème la question
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'un club ou une
ligue juge devoir en arriver à jusqu'à
saisir la justice pour pour pouvoir
obtenir des documents de comptabilité de
la Fédération c'est plutôt ça le sujet
là en fait ils disent qu'il y avait un
refus de communiquer les
documents non non je
je ils ont été transmis donc il les
analysent maintenant et qu'il disent ce
qui ce qui va ce qui ne va pas encore
une fois je je je le répète dans la LI
PACA il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes ça c'est clair interne interne
avec des avec des licenciers qui étaient
commandité il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont hein pour pour essayer de
déstabiliser cette cette ligue et je
crois qu'elle a tenu elle a tenu bon et
que jusqu'à présent j'ai pas entendu
dire qu'il y avait quoi que ce soit de
d'illégal donc je me réfère à ça alors
peut-être que dans les documents
comptables il y a rien d'illégal mais en
tout cas la le tribunal administratif a
jugé
illégal le refus de la FFR de
communiquer ces documents donc il y a
quand même quelque chose d'illégal même
si c'est pas ce qu' le contenu des
documents peut-être juste juste pour
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière
parce que vous nous avez dit que il y
avait pas d'obligation de faire des
appels d'offre en ce qui vous concerne
et moi donc ma question c'est dans quel
cas est-ce que vous estimez qu'une
fédération doit faire un appel d'offre
pour pour le
sponsoring qui est le plus vu sponsoring
maillot qui est le plus vu c'est une
évidence d vous êtes sur vous êtes sur
un maillot d'une équipe de de
sport vous êtes le sponsor majeur de la
fédération et moi j'im dire que pour ce
pour ce sponsor là effectivement moi je
souhaite qu'il y a un appel d'offre je
pense que ce serait logique qu'il y ait
un appel
d'offre ok donc uniquement sur la
question des maillots sur tout le reste
ça peut passer en dehors des appels
d'offre mais c'est pas que ça peut
passer mais vous avez l'impression qu'il
y a qu' qui qui a PL Tor de partenaair
mais on il faut aller les chercher avec
les dents croyez-moi les partenaires
c'est c'est pas les appels d'offre qui
vont changer les choses ils se battent
pas sur le sponsor maillot on en a eu
qu'un à la sortie qui est venu qui a
voulu qui a voulu payer et je vois
qu'ils ont reconduit le même hein donc
si quelqu'un avait voulu prendre sa
place s'il avait eu plusieurs
prétendants je crois que il se ils
auraient pris euh le plus le le plus au
Fran est certainement un autre que celui
qui occupe aujourd'hui l'espace
de une question notre collègue Claudia
rouo oui euh tout d'abord bonjour
monsieur ministre je je reviens
juste à cette histoire entre la Ligue
pas et la Fédération s'il y avait rien à
cacher pourquoi vous n'avez pas donné
les documents enfin ça ça paraît
incroyable parce que est-ce que c'était
une demande du président de la ligue
paka ou alors vous aviez quelques
craintte parce que s'il y avait rien à
cacher il y avait aucune raison de pas
transmettre t documents c'est quand même
assez étonnant de ne pas suivre
l'injonction d'un
tribunal pour pour vous dire la vérité
oui vous avez vous avez entièrement
raison j'étais pas au courant qu'on
avait pas transmis je me rappelle du du
tribunal de Versailles qui nous dit
c'est illégal mais j'ai pas suivi
l'affaire voir s'ils avaient transmis
s'ils avaient pas transmis voilà la
vérité et ça a été fait donc maintenant
ils vont il vont ils vont regarder dans
les
détails une question notre collègue
François pimal oui bonjour monsieur la
porte le le 12 novembre 2022 vous étiez
toujours président de la Fédération
Française de
Rugby c'est la première sélection de
Bastien chalurau et vous savez qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de bruit là avant et un peu
pendant la coupe du monde au sujet de sa
sélection d'abord venu d'acteurs du
rugby qui se sont émus du fait qu'il
était sélectionné eu égard qu'il avait
une procédure judiciaire en cours pour
des faits de violence à caractère
raciste le l'appel a eu lieu récemment
et bientôt le jugement sera rendu et on
s à quoi s'en tenir mais ma question est
comment se fait-il que le 22 novembre
lorsque Monsieur chaluro est sélectionné
la Fédération française de rugby ne se
dit pas que forcément ce cas va prêter à
discussion ou interrogation légitime de
la part d'un certain nombre
d'observateurs rubbistique ou médiatique
et qu'il y a des victimes potentielles
qui qui existent aussi avantier il y
avait le témoign de Monsieur Yannick
larget qui est une des personnes qui a
déposé plainte contre Monsieur chalurau
et et qui qui se considère comme victime
de sa part pourquoi N a n'y a-t-il pas
eu un dispositif de la Fédération
française de rugby pour expliquer la
sélection du joueur pour expliquer aussi
dans quel contexte et est-ce qu'il y a
eu des discussions avec le joueur avant
pour l'intégrer pour savoir ce qu'il en
était de sa procédure de son état
d'esprit mais aussi pour communiquer sur
le fait que c'était très important pour
la Fédération Française de lutter contre
le racisme et peut-être l'intégrer euh
alors lui ni la caractérisation raciste
de l'agression c'est son droit il est
présumé innocent à ce stade mais montrer
que la Fédération française est
volontariste sur cette question là et
plus largement parce que tout à l'heure
vous avez dit c'est euh c'est au club de
prendre leur responsabilités sur les
questions de racisme et on est d'accord
et là-dessus il faut quand même relever
que le stade toulousin à l'époque de
l'histoire a fait preuve vraiment de
célérité et d'exemplarité sur la manière
dont il a gérer l'affaire du moins
d'après les les deux personnes qui ont
été victimes des coups mais au niveau de
la Fédération Française de rudby quelles
actions vous avez mises en place sachant
que si on fait une revue de presse on a
on a fait cet exercice ne serurait-ce
que pour 2023 il y a quasiment tous les
weekends des faits de racisme vis-à-vis
de joueurs de rugby qui viennent de
supporters sur le terrain ou alors
vis-à-vis d'arbitre parfois et quelles
grandes actions avez-vous mis en œuvre
déjà je je je vous
répondrai puisque vous avez soulevé ce
problème durant la Coupe du Monde
pourquoi pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait
en novembre en novembre 2022 vous aussi
ah je je vais vous répondre simplement
parce que même si je suis toulousin j'ai
un petit prisme pour le foot plus que
pour le rugby et donc je je n'ai pas et
comme beaucoup de personnes je pense
analyser le CV de chaque joueur de rugby
sélectionné pour un test match je crois
c'était contre l'Afrique du Sud et leur
passif tout simplement et je pense qu'on
est beaucoup dans ce cas on pour
répondre à la question si vous vous en
avez parlé c'est la présomption
d'innocence c'est aussi simple que ça
voilà quand Fabien Galtier a
sélectionné churau bien sûr que tout le
monde était au courant de ce qui s'était
passé vous savez le rugby c'est un
microcosme et vous avez bien fait de
dire que le stat toulousain c'était une
affaire euh j'ai j'ai envie de dire pas
interne puisque les victimes nétaient
pas ne jouent pas au stade toulousin
mais de de de gens qui habitent au même
endroit que des clubs voisin et cetera
et que je pense que le saintoulousien a
bien fait effectivement de prendre la
décision qu'il a prise à ce moment-là
c'est une certitude après il y a comme
je vous disait la présomption
d'innocence là on peut pas dire on va
pas sélectionner les garçons
imaginez-vous qu'il n ait rien à la
sortie je crois qu'encore une fois ou
alors ou alors il faut supprimer la
présumption d'innocence voilà on la
supprime on parle de plus rien alors à
ce moment-là d qu'ilation on pe voilà ok
il peut pas jouer voilà c'est en ce sens
encore encore une fois et puis je suis
comme vous hein vous savez quand fabien
a
sélectionné Bastien chalurot d'abord moi
j'étais en Nouvelle-Zélande j'étais au
phase finale de de de de la Coupe du
Monde Féminine donc j'étais pas j'étais
pas en France tout le mois novembre j'ai
pas vu j'ai pas vu de match j'avais
entendu parler du cas chaliro hein faut
dire les choses comme elles sont mais
pas dans les détails certainement pas et
qu' encore une fois voilà la
présempption d'innocence fait que tant
qu'il est pas condamné tant qu'il ne
tant qu'il n'a pas d'interdiction de
jouer pour l'équipe de France c'est
difficile c'est difficile pour un
sélectionneur de dire on va pas on va
pas le prendre voilà et quant à tout ce
qu'on a mis en place je crois que vous
en avez déjà parlé avec avec Laurent
gabanini on est une fédération j'ai
envie de dire modèle exemplaire ce
serait prétentieux mais modèle en terme
de de tout ce qu'on a batti he que ce
soit
la la c3pr et cetera et cetera avec les
tichapachou l'l en charge de leslu en
charge pardon de de tout ce qui est
violence sexuelle et autes on est on est
euh une fédération exemplaire tout le
monde nous le dit la preuve c'est quand
on a créé la cadette vous savez ce que
c'est la cadette la commission anti
antidiscrimination égalité des
traitements on est la seule fédération
l' mis en place alors oui je je je l'ai
mis en place parce que j'ai été
confronté à un cas comme ça un cas de de
de de d'une fille qui est venue me voir
un transgre qui me dit on m'interdit de
jouer au rugby mais pourquoi on
Tinterdit de jouer au rugby pour telle
et telle et telle raison et
effectivement W rugby dont j'étais
membre
disait interdiction de jouer pour les
tranger interdiction et moi ça m'a
heurté parce que quand je quand quand je
le quand je le regardais je me disais
oui mais mais mais pourquoi donc je me
suis appuyé sur jibémol qui est un
docteur en sciences je sais pas si vous
le connaissez docteur sciences sciences
des Sports à Montpellier qui est
lui-même trans genre donc il connaît
parfaitement le truc il m'a dit Bernard
c'est pas possible on peut pas interdire
et cetera et cetera j'ai dit mais
comment on fait moi j'étais démuni c'est
je n'avais pas les compétences pour
créer la cadette et il m'a dit voilà ce
qu'il faut faire ça ça ça j'ai dit mais
il faut que tu le fasses toi moi j'ai
personne la fédération qui capable mieux
que toi de de créer
cette cette entité et donc il a créé la
cadette et quand je vois qu'aujourd'hui
toutes les fédérations n nous nous le
reprennent quand je vois qu'on a donné
l'autorisation à cette personne de jouer
au début il y avait trois trjar
aujourd'hui il y en a si je dis une
multitude ce serait exagéré mais il y en
a beaucoup plus parce que ils ont senti
que voilà et et je suis fier de ça et et
surtout je suis fier du travail réalisé
par JB avec cette cadette vous savez
quand on fait un tournoi inclusif durant
la Coupe du monde avec des équipes qui
viennent du monde entier rubis ma Prat
ça s'appelait c'est nous qui l'avons
initié voilà donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on fait le maximum je peux vous garantir
que la Fédération Française de Ruby que
ce soit en terme de lutte contre le
racisme de lutte contre l'homophobie et
cetera on a fait
beaucoup alors sur sur pour revenir
rapidement sur l'affaire chalurau mon
propos c'est pas de dire que monsieur
chalurau ne devait pas être sélectionné
vous avez raison il était présumé
innocent mais à partir du moment où
c'est vous avez dit c'est un microcosme
le rugby et moi l'affaire je l'ai
apprise par des gens qui sont amateurs
plus que moi de rugby et qui m'ont
alerté dessus comme ils ont alerté
d'autres gens à la veille de la Coupe du
monde mais à partir du moment où il est
décidé décidé de sélectionner un joueur
dont il SA dont on sait qu'il est partie
prenante d'une affaire qui remet en
cause sa probité en matière
en l'occurrence de lutte contre le
racisme mais ça pourrait être sur autre
chose il y a eu aussi une affaire avec
un autre joueur sur des violences
conjugal notamment il me semble normal
qu'à mon sens la fédération en question
fasse une communication ne serait-ce que
peut-être parce que le joueur a changé
ou s'est investi ou ou a des des choses
à dire sur le sujet or en novembre
dernier ça n'a pas été le cas ensuite
sur ce que vous dites par rapport à
toutes les actions que vous avez faite
certainement il y en a-t-il
eu de manière conséquente mais
visiblement pas assez parce qu'on a
encore il a il y a eu le le fait du
match entre Vernet notamment des
Pyrénées Orientales avec une bagarre
générale avec des insultes racistes qui
ont été proférés à l'encontre des
joueurs de de Vernay et récemment on a
auditionné aussi monsieur Baky meit qui
lui-même a été en tant qu'entraîneur
victime d'insulte raciste de la part de
son entraîneur adjoint et qui a eu
quasiment aucune écoute de la part de la
Fédération française de rugby donc il y
a il y a quand même un problème qui est
récurrent qui est latant qui demeure et
vous est-ce que vous avez des pistes à
ce stade pour faire en sorte que que ça
cesse parce que ça ça remet en question
aussi le fait de pouvoir jouer de
manière apaisée et sine au rugby quelle
que soit son origine euh sociale raciale
et cetera raison mais mais le risque
zéro n'existe pas c'est pas parce que
vous mettez des choses en place que de
suite c'est nous serons plus confrontés
à des problèmes de racisme c'est comme
la
lutte pour les antisémites croyez que
parce qu'on va faire une loi c'est fini
il y aura plus il y aura plus d'actes
antisémite malheureusement le risque
zéro il existe pas ce qu'il faut c'est
en combattre un maximum mettre mettre
mettre des outils qui font que il y en
aura de moins en moins mais
malheureusement je le répète le risque
zéro il existe pas et vous me dites ça
il y en a il y en a sur les terrains
mais oui mais on a mis des choses en
place sur les terrains
donc il faut les appliquer c'est aussi
simple que ça mais malheureusement je
vous dis pas ne vous inquiétez plus ne
vous inquiétez pas il y aura plus d'acte
de racisme sur les terrains de rugby
c'est pas possible c'est pas vrai
malheureusement hein c'est la société
est
tellement fait que il y a toujours des
individus qui voilà qui se comportent
mal et il faut faire en sorte de les
exclure d'abord de
les de les réprimander d'accord de les
envoyer devant la justice c'est ce que
nous avons fait c'est toutes ces actions
que nous mettons et quant au au au au
cas que vous me parlez c'est un joueur
professionnel d'abord c'est un joueur
professionnel donc c'était la Ligue
Nationale de Rugby qui est en charge de
ça c'est pas la fédération mais je suis
surpris sincèrement que ce joueur ne
soit pas au courant de tout ce que la
Fédération française de rugby a mis en
place je sais qu'il est venu il il a
fait cette déclaration il y a pas de
problème je dis pas qu'il vous a menti
loin de là mais je suis surpris qu'il
n'it pas connaissance de tout ce que la
Fédération Française rub a mis en place
pour accompagner justement les personnes
les victimes comme lui puisque éement il
était victime de de racisme par un
entraîneur je crois c'était dans un club
je crois hein c'est pas par un
adversaire c'est si je bien c'est par un
club par son
entraîneur une question de Monsieur
Stéphane Mazard oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre fort de votre
expérience sur le terrain et et sur le
bord du terrain est-ce que vous vous
pensez que que
qu'un stade doit être bah le reflet
finalement de la société avec des
expressions
diverses parfois
radicale parfois injurieuse diffamatoire
enfin bon voilà un lieu d'expression euh
où est-ce qu'il faut au contraire
sanctuariser l'aire de jeu et une
enceinte sportive de manière générale
parce que justement c'est un lieu où on
doit mettre de
côté toutes les aspérités de de notre
société et un lieu où on fait du commun
et et quelque chose de positif et et à
ce titre est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut aller plus loin
sur la recherche de ceux qui dans une
enceinte sportive avec les moyens
modernes cause des troubles et et
engager des poursuites et avveit des
sanctions à la clé contre ces gens-là
donc ça c'est ma première question puis
ensuite une question différente c'est la
Fédération française de rugby avait eu
le projet de de son grand
stade à l'image de ce qui se fait en
Angleterre avec tukenham l'appropriation
de l'infrastructure sportive qui permet
à partir de cette infrastructure de de
de développer un business model est-ce
que ça vous semble pertinent pour une
fédération nous on se pose beaucoup la
question de savoir aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui pourrait améliorer le fonctionnement
des fédérations est-ce que donner aux
fédérations des moyens notamment par
l'infrastructure sportive de développer
un business model un petit peu autonome
euh est-ce que ça vous semble être une
bonne
chose pour répondre à la première
question oui je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous tolérance zéro bien
sûr qu'il faut sanctariser les les les
les les les terrains de sport les stades
même il doit on doit y vivre des des des
moments
conviviaux de passion de respect enfin
je parle de tous les sports je parle pas
que de rugby et il est évident qu'à
partir du moment où quelqu'un se
comporte mal mais j'ai envie de dire moi
le premier si je suis à un stade et que
j'entend la personne à côté de moi ou
devant moi qui insulte ou qui qui tient
des propes racistes je serai le premier
à le reprimander
je crois que ça vient ça aussi quoi faut
pas attendre tout de de tout le monde
moi je serai le premier dire comment tu
te comportes pourquoi tu parles comme ça
je veux dire la prre des choses ou
tolérance zé faut sortir ces gens des
stad c'est une
évidence le plus beau des exemples c'est
le football anglais moi j'adore le
football anglais mais il y a 20 ans
c'était insupportable c'était
insupportable le Parc des Princes moi
j'ai habité j'ai habité r pendant 10 ans
j'ai vu des choses mais je me disais
mais c'est pas possible où on est les
gens obligés de venir enfin les
policiers à cheval tellement c'était
tellement c'était la guerre tellement
c'était des insultes de partout les
supporters arrivai c'était bagarre sur
bagarre C c'était fou je me dis mais
c'est pas ça le sport quand même et il
fa force de reconnaître que Monsieur le
prou je crois de de mémoire à l'époque
président a fait un travail considérable
aujourd'hui vous allez au stade vous
allez dans un dans vous allez voir un
spectacle vous allez voir un match il
tout tout est nickel il y a pas il y a
pas de propos raciste moi de temps en
temps quand j'y vais au part des princes
et je suis pas dans la présidentielle
j'ai pas de c'est terminé moi j'ai connu
les fa inverse il y a 20 ans j'ai connu
les fait où vous ne rentrez pas au stade
d'ailleurs un jour j'ai amené tout le
staff de l'équipe de France parce que
nous
étions en plein tournoation voir un
match mais les mecs il m'ont dit
reviendra plus et le football anglais
c'était ça et aujourd'hui allez à
Liverpool allez à Chelsea allez à
Manchester mais vous allez véritablement
dans un endroit de paix quoi dans un
endroit où on va chercher des émotions
du sport bien sûr on on est pour une
équipe on est contre l'autre bien sûr
c'est ça le sport mais eux ils ont fait
ce qu'il fallait moi je suis pour ça
tolérance zéro on en veut pas des gens
des gens qui se comportent mal c'est sûr
quand à la la deuxième question c'est la
première chose que que j'ai faite quand
j'ai été élu président de la Fédération
française de rugby mais si on avait pas
fait ça si on n'avait pas fait ça
aujourd'hui nous serions sous tutelle
nous serions s sous tutelle nous devions
ont remboursé 45 millions d'euros par an
mais vous avez lu les les bilans de la
Fédération française de rugby 45
millions d'euros par an nous devions
rembourser donc au bout de la première
année nous aurions été sous tutelle j'ai
envie de dire sil a une chose que j'ai
bien fait la Fédération c'est d'arrêter
cette folie c'est impossible qui plusit
à 50 km de Paris c la folie alors après
pour aller dans votre sens une
fédération elle a besoin de ressources
comment on va chercher d'autres
ressources mais c'est la même chose pour
les clubs c'est exactement la même chose
pour les clubs qui sont
aujourd'hui alimentés par des par des
par des milliardaaires par des
millionnaires et cetera et ceetera le
jour où ces gens ne sont plus là que
vont faire que vont faire ces clubs là
faut construire des valeurs ajoutées
autour qui fassent qu'il ait des revenus
qui des valeurs ajoutées qui des revenus
additionnels qui fassent que que ça
remplace ce que le milliardaire met tous
les ans sans quoi ces clubs ils vont
mourir et une fédération c'est la même
chose comment on va chercher des valeurs
ajoutées alors nous notre volonté je
suppose que c'est toujours toujours
celle du président actuel on avait dit
on on stoppe le le le grand stade mais
on veut négocier avec le Stade de France
une fois que la que la convention sera
terminée pour être partie penante de de
du stat de France nous aujourd'hui
grosso modo je crois qu'on payit dans
les 1 million 1 million 100 par match on
payit la location du stade 1 million 1
million 100 par match moi ce que je veux
c'est qu'on fasse partie intégrante de
la future convention qu'on pe pas qu'on
amène effectivement toujours Noain
et qu'ensemble on développe d'autres
activités mais c'est pas notre métier
nous donc il faut il faut il faut
s'associer à quelqu'un qui sait faire ça
qui sait faire des spectacles qui sait
faire truc moi je pense qu'il faudrait
que le foot et le rugby le fassent
ensemble viennent ça dans ce dans ce
dans ce futur repreneur entre guillemets
et s'associer avec un gens qui développe
le stade et puis que ce stade te serve à
avoir des des des revenus additionnels
et pas nécessairement tu payes un
million et puis c'est tout non ça ça
nous coûte cher donc c'est évident que
si on veut progresser encore une fois
cet argent c'est pour le monde amateurin
c'est pas pour payer les joueurs ou pour
payer le monde professionnel donc il
faut c'est une évidence qu'il faut
s'intégrer maintenant dans le futur
repreneur du Stade de France pour qu'on
ait beaucoup moins de frais et et qui
plusit moins de frais et plus de revenus
mais il en est question on a fait
beaucoup de réunions je sais pas où ça
en est bien sûr maintenant mais à
l'époque on a fait beaucoup de réunions
avec la digess à l'époque c'était Jean
Castex qui qui qui menit cela avant
qu'il soit Premier ministre et on a
beaucoup beaucoupré pour faire en sorte
ben de trouver la meilleure solution
pour aider les fédérations à avoir des
moyens
supplémentaires Claudia rouau vous aviez
une
question pardon excusez-moi oui j'avais
une question sur la présomption
d'innocence vous avez abordé ce sujet
par rapport au au propos raciste du
joueur dans l'hypothèse où il y a du
rugby féminin aujourd'hui parce que
c'est quand même souvent dans ce sens-l
mais ça peut être aussi avec des jeunes
enfants vous avez un entraîneur qui est
accusé de viol sur un de joueur
qu'est-ce que vous faites alors au nom
de la présemption de naissance de
d'innocence vous le laissez en contact
avec des jeunes ou vous le suspendez
immédiatement supendu immédiatement non
mais ça va loin quand
même non mais c'est VI ça veut dire
qu'il il y a acte c'est vérifié et
cetera et cetera donc là de suite c'est
c'est c'est pas possible oui enfin
tant qu'on n'est pas condamné on est
présumé innocent donc il y a là dans
dans l'affaire du joueur c'est c'est
juste parce que je pense qu'on
sous-estime aujourd'hui sans doute de
trop des des des propos racistes et tout
et c'est pour ça que ça ça prend des
proportions donc vous avez vous
considérez qu' a présempption innocence
dans un cas et dans l'autre vous ne
prendrez en fait c'est juste une
question de risque
alors question de risque effectivement
moi le B char je le connaissais pas pour
pour vous dire la vérité je l'ai appris
moi quand s quand bas chalero est
sélectionné je suis comme vous
j'apprends que il y a il y a eu ça mais
je suis pas au courant du du dossier
j'ai pas étudié le dossier et cetera je
savais même pas qu'il y avait un procès
moi sincèrement je savais je je le
savais pas là vous me parlez d'un cas
avéré viol et cetera qui qui est sous
nos yeuxéré donc c'est la sction est
immédiate il faut écarter de suite C cet
éducateur ça c'est une
évidence juste peut-être parce que
tout au long de de de ces de cette de
ces auditions on a beaucoup entendu bien
sûr la notion de présomption d'innocence
sauf que la suspension à titre
conservatoire par exemple d'un joueur
euh dont on sait et au moment où il a
été sélectionné je crois que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure tout le monde était
au courant euh ou tout voilà bah oui
dans la région tout le monde tout le
monde savait donc à minima le club enfin
voilà dans cette région là tout le monde
savait la la suspension ça veut pas dire
qu'on considère que la personne est
coupable ça veut juste dire qu'on prend
ses responsabilités et qu'on suspend la
personne pour éviter soit que d'autres
faits se se reproduisent je pense à des
à des insulttes racistes homophobes ou
ou d'autres choses ou que ce soit sur
les questions des VSS donc j'entends la
question de présomption d'innocence mais
en fait on l'a entendu en presque en fil
conducteur sur toute cette commission
d'enquête et ça a toujours été peut-être
un argument qui a été avancé aussi
parfois par certaines fédérations
lorsqu'elles n'ont pas
pr la pleine mesure finalement des actes
qui ont été commis et de leur gravité
finalement mais c'est le cas
effectivement sur B chur nous on dit les
choses comm mais vous dites de suspendre
mais de mémoire c'était 4 ou 5 ans avant
que ça s'était passé je ne sais pas
exactement c'était pas là on parle de
novembre 2022 c'était c'était pas en
septembre 2022 qu'on soit d'accord donc
le suspendre alors il il aurait fallu le
suspendre 4 an
20 alors la question qui va avec c'est
est-ce que vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui si un sportif tenait des
propos racistes homophobes discriminants
ou même sur aurait des comportements
inappropriés du point de vue des
violences sexuelles et sexistes est-ce
que la suspension serait
immédiate mais c'est Al encore une
fois il y a le monde professionnel et le
monde
amateur qui est g non non mais je vous
explique géré par
attribu à la Fédération ce qu'elle a à
faire ell sissent pas dans le dans le
monde professionnel il est clair que
s'il y a des propos racistes avéré comme
viol sous nos yeux c'est clair que la S
est immédiate il y a pas on va pas
attendre le procès il y a pas de il y a
pas de il y a pas de présumption
d'innocence on est entièrement d'accord
là-dessus il y a pas de souci pour moi
quand je dis tolérance zéro c'est
tolérance zéro mais dans ce cas de
figure d'abord nous pas au courant on
l'apprend et et et qu'est-ce qu'on sait
on me dit il y a eu ça il y a eu ça mais
moi je savais rien du tout vous savez
demain c'est trop facile hein demain je
j'ai j'ai un match je vais dire à une
personne tiens porte porte plainte po
raciste contre ce joueur comme ça le
l'équipe adverse va le suspendre il faut
quand même un petit peu de faut quand
même des preuves quoi je veux dire quand
il y a un un viol et que c'est et que
c'est avéré les preuves elles sont là
quoi je veux dire une fille elle porte
pas plainte pour pour viol euh pour euh
pour rien donc il faut il il faut se
prévenir quand
même une question de Monsieur Stéphane
Bichou je sais pas quel micro je prends
je va prendre celui-là celui-là
peut-être c'est mieux
ah benah oui de MICR rien que ça merci
Madame merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voulais revenir
sur rapidement en fait mais sur sur la
question des des propos et des
comportements discriminatoires au sein
des dans les enceintes
sportives moi je je alors c'est à la
fois une observation une question au
final
c'est au fil des des différentes
auditions évidemment cette question est
revenue régulièrement
et je crois qu'il faut s'en féliciter
les
auditionnés à votre instar nous ont très
régulièrement dit tolérance
zéro tolérance zéro il faut il faut
pardon pour le terme il faut virer des
gens qui se comporte mal ce que vous
nous dites
et vous avez à juste titre pris
l'exemple du houiganisme en Angleterre
il y a une grosse vingtaine d'années et
hier soir nous iionnion le président de
la Ligue de football professionnel et
nous avons eu ces ces échanges également
et Vincent Labrune nous disant moi ça me
rend fou de voir ça et et
vraiment c'est quasi un copier-collé de
ce que vous nous dites bon ça c'est il y
a pas du tout de mise en cause dans ma
bouche mais ça c'est le discours et on
le
partage en revanche le
constat
malheureux c'est que dans les faits ça
continue
et en fait moi je je j'ai pleinement
conscience on a pleinement conscience au
sein de cette commission de la
difficulté de la complexité du sujet
mais je voilà c'est pour ça que c'est
une question observation moi je m'étonne
quand même de de cette farouche volonté
des dirigeants des différentes
fédérations à vouloir on va dire le
terme
éradiquer ses comportements
et il existe un certain nombre d'outils
qui ont été évoqués hier soir
pour sanctuariser effectivement ces
enceintes mais on y arrive pas comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquez au fond
parce que quand un président de
fédération
aussi
puissante que le rugby que le football
ou d'autres tiennent ses discours là et
qu'au final derrière ça suit pas
vraiment et qu'on en est encore à
échanger sur tolérance zéro et cetera et
cetera et regardez ce qui s'est passé en
Angleterre et regardez ce qui s'est
passé dans dans tel dans tel autre pays
ces pays-là oui ont pris un certain
nombre de de
dispositions pour atteindre les
objectifs il y a un problème en France
ou ou
pas d'abord je
je je dirais que dans le dans le monde
du rugby que ce soit le monde
professionnel de club ou où les match
des équipes de France féminine masculine
moins de 20 ans il y a jamais un
problème dans ce stade en on a vécu la
Coupe du monde de rugby en France il y a
pas eu un cas de racisme alors qu'il y a
eu 48 matchs durant la
compétition j'ai envie de dire qu'on est
un petit peu à l'abri permettez-moi
l'expression le rugby c'est
malheureusement pas le cas du football
et je connais bien Vincent la prune et
je comprends qu'ils se disent que c'est
compliqué moi le premier qui suis
passionné de football quand je vois ce
qui se passe dans des stades je me dis
mais c'est pas possible quoi mais encore
une fois le risque zéro n'existe pas ou
alors il faut faire comme en Angleterre
alors mettez les places à 150 €. mettez
toutes les places à 150
€. vous allez vite éradiquer les choses
mais c'est est-ce que est-ce que c'est
ça la bonne chose on va priver mon frère
qui n'a pas les moyens qui est content
d'aller voir jouer un match de football
à 15 € ou à 30 € on va le priver parce
que lui qui qui se comporte bien aès bon
il faut prendre des décisions hein les
anglais l'ont fait mais j'ai envie de
dire c'est vous qui votez les lois c'est
pas moi hein c'est pas moi qui vote les
lois donc faites faites en sorte que ça
se passe plus
oui mais les LO
mais mais oui mais je suis d'accord les
lois existent mais vous empêcherez pas
un gars rentrer au stade malgré la loi
et de dire je m'en fous de la loi je
veux insulter les gens c'est ça le
problème c'est ça le problme une
question de Madame la rapporteur pardon
oui moi j'aimerais juste que vous
précisz ou en tout cas vous reveniez sur
ce que vous venez de dire quand vous
dites si vous voulez mettez toutes les
places à 150 € qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire mais le houuganisme qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé je parle de ce qui s'est
passé en
Angleterre d'accord pour
éradiquer le l'ouiganisme ils ont mis
des places très très cheres d'accord
donc c'était donné à une certaine
population entre guillemets mais moi je
suis contre ça moi je suis contre ça le
sport c'est le contraire le sport ça
peut ça peut pas être un endroit où où
ne vont que des gens qui ont des ont des
qui ont des moyens alors ils onont fait
et on est cont parce qu'ils ont il y a
plus de luganisme mais on oublie quand
même que c'est très cher c'est très cher
d'aller d'aller dans un stade de de de
de de football alors petit à petit petit
à petit ça petit à petit ça ça revient
mais c'est ce qu'ils ont fait dès le
départ et moi je suis et moi je suis
contre ça et moi je suis contre mais
mais encore une fois il faut bien
reconnaître que mais c'est ce qu'ils ont
pris comme AX ils y sont arrivés même si
aujourd'hui je suppose que les pris
redescendre à partir du moment où il y
en a plus ils doivent redescendre les
prix je suppose encore une fois je suis
pas dans les club anglais de football
mais c'est une des c'est une des des
comment dirais-je des résolutions qu'ils
ont prises pour éradiquer les l'uganisme
après ils ont mis les matchs à midi
aussi pourquoi ils ont mis les match à
midi parce que souvent quand il
gardaient les match le soir les mecs il
buvaient toute la toute la toute la
journée le soir ils
étaient plein de bière permettez-moi
l'expression et il cassait tout match à
midi silav 10h donc il y avait pas de
problème à midi il y avait pas de de
d'obstruction dans les stades mais bon
vous vous le dites il y a des lois qui
existent mais malheureusement si je peux
je peux vous garantir que tous les
présidents ils sont écurés de ça parce
qu'encore une fois c'est des minorités
heureusement he pour nous heureusement
que c'est des minorités mais on narrive
pas
effectivement non juste en en en rebond
de ce
que de la réponse que que vous nous
faites alors moi je partage avec vous
qu'effectivement c'est une minorité et
c'est justement parce que c'est une
minorité c'est particulièrement énervant
euh l'exemple l'exemple
anglaison c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils ont
tapé au portefeuille comme on dit ça a
eu ses effets c'est vraisemblablement
pas le modèle que l'on souhaite importer
en France et ça moi je partage partage
ça avec vous mais encore une fois c'est
cette c'est c'est ce difficile équilibre
et et vous nous dites euh il faut il
faut faire évoluer la loi vous êtes
parlementaire bon vous avez aussi été
vous avez été
ministre des
sport justement alors je sais pas moi je
suis arrivé en retard je m'en excuse
est-ce que je sais pas si cette question
là a été posée est-ce que vous lorsque
vous étiez membres du gouvernement vous
vous êtes emparé de ce sujet et si oui
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui a été fait et et
encore une
fois en dehors et moi j'ai pas non plus
de baguette magique hein mais c'est vrai
qu'on a auditionné et je je je je vais
un peu au-delà du rugby parce que j'ai
aussi un prisme comme mon collègue comme
certains de mes collègues ici
football ce qui veut pas dire que j'aime
pas du tout le rugby c'est pas du tout
ça mais mais comment voilà pour nous
c'est une vraie interrogation et comme
cette commission elle a vocation à
proposer un certain nombre d'actions et
donc à faire uvre utile on a besoin de
cet éclairage et et on est très bon dans
le constat dans la dénonciation mais
dans l'action on l'IT un peu moins on a
déjà
évoquébut ce que vous avez mais moi je
crois fort à la communication dans les
stades moi j'y crois fort à ça quand la
Champions League met respect non racisme
et cetera et cetera je crois que c'est
de l'information qu'on infuse à à des
gens qui sont dans le dans le public et
si on le faisait au football attention
et cetera et
cetera ne tolérez pas que l'individu à
vos côté se comporte mal et cetera et je
pense que si on donn ces informations je
pense encore une fois et que moi le
premier quoi même si j'ai pas besoin des
informations si quelqu'un se
comportement mal à côté je vais lui dire
mais peut-être qu'il y en a qui osent
pas qui ont dit attendez vous avez Pasu
ce qu'ils ont dit faut pas parler comme
ça monsieur je crois que la première des
choses c'est elle vient de nous de la
proximité des gens qui qui qui parlent
qui qui parlent comme ça donc moi je
crois beaucoup à ces informations dans
les stades le football nous sommes
contre le Racim et cetera et cetera et
cetera je crois que tout ça il faut
l'infuser sans arrêt sans arrêt sans
arrêt pendant les matchs alors bien sûr
match amateur où il y a 20 personnes
dans la tribune on on parle pas de la
même chose mais dans dans dans dans dans
ces dans ces terrain dans ces stades
professionnels où ça se passe parce que
ça se passe malheureusement dans des
clubs de première division en France he
au football mais il faut je crois et je
surtout pas leur donner de leçons mais
encore plus communiqué non contre le
racisme non contre l'homophobie non
contre c non contre ça si vous avez des
gens qui se comportent comme ça à côté
de vous dans le stade il faut leur dire
de pas le faire et cetera et cetera je
pense que ça va amener à la retenue je
pense encore une fois mais après il y a
pas de baguette magique comme vous le
disiez alors juste ouis euh par rapport
à ça je en fait on entend sauf que nous
on a plutôt le sentiment que ça fait
maintenant 30 40 ans qu'on nous dit il
faut sensibiliser les gens sur la
question du racisme on avait d'ailleurs
eu l'occasion
d'auditionner monsieur turam ici qui
avait eu un exposé très fort sur
l'action du racisme et le fait que
parfois peut-être il faut aller beaucoup
plus loin notamment sur plutôt la notion
de
déconstruction de des mécanismes qui
conduisent au racisme à l'homophobie au
discrimination et c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus poussé finalement que une
simple sensibilisation à cette question
et et et c'est pour ça que en fait moi
j'ai voulu revenir sur la question du
prix des billets parce que en réalité on
parle d'houiganisme et bon certains pays
ont fait ce choix-l mais quand on parle
de racisme et de discrimination on est
dans autre chose et pour le coup faire
le parallèle entre les deux et expliquer
qu'il faudrait augmenter le prix des
billets ça laisse sous-entendre que
finalement seul les plus précaires et
les plus pauvres euh aurait des
comportements euh euh enfin voilà des
des des propos homophobes ouou racistes
dans les stades c'est pour ça que voilà
je donc vous avez précisé la pensée sur
l'houiganisme et c'est et c'est tant
mieux parce qu'effectivement je pense
que c'est pas du tout la même chose et
euh et je pense pas que la solution
d'augmenter les prix dans les stades
aujourd'hui en tout cas en France et
c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire mais c'est
je pense pas que ça soit ça qui résolve
notre problème actuel mais on voit bien
que la sensibilisation en tout cas telle
qu'on a pu la mettre en place depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années et bien
elle fonctionne pas puisque y compris
alors on parle du Ruby ce matin mais
c'est le cas dans le foot par exemple on
a plutôt le sentiment et d'ailleurs ça a
été dit hier qu'il y a une explosion des
phénomènes de violence et de racisme et
de d'homophobie dans les stades
notamment depuis enfin après le retour
du covid donc on voit bien que tout ce
qui a été mis en place en terme de
sensibilisation aujourd'hui n'a pas
fonctionné donc est-ce que c'est des
sanctions plus fortes est-ce que c'est
des ateliers de déconstruction plus fort
voilà c'est je pense voilà au
aujourd'hui il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin que ça
moi je suis enèement d'accord
entièrement d'accord avec vous sur le
sur le nous il y a pas de houligan
aujourd'hui c'est c'est il y a pas de
lganisme mais entièrement d'accord qu'il
faut il faut frapper plus fort c'est une
évidence sans quoi on sera toujours à
sa'uditionner à se dire il faut faire il
faut frapper plus fort il faut interdir
mais il faut les prévenir vous risquez
d'être interdit de sport vous risquez
interdit de licence première fois un an
après c'est à vie en je sais pas mais il
est évident qu'il faut éradiquer ces
gens qui se comportent mal c'est quoi on
y arrivera pas alors je savais pas qu'il
y avait une recruaissance depuis le
depuis le covid mais encore une fois je
je je le dis dans le monde du rugby on
est on est quand même on est quand même
privilégié quoi on a pas ça vous disiez
t monsieur le député que il il y a
beaucoup de cas de de de racisme moi j'
allais beaucoup j'y vais moins voir des
matchs amateurs j'ai jamais été
confronté jamais été confronté à un
problème de racisme et pourtant j''y
allé tous les weekends et et jamais j'ai
été confronté al peut-être jeis passé
les goûtes mais je dis pas qu'il y en a
pas hein qu'on soit d'accord
mais dans le monde professionnel déjà il
il y en a pas hein vous allez voir stat
Toulous Rochel il y a pas de problème de
racisme ça n'existe pas j'ai jamais vu
un problème de racisme ça ça n'existe
pas et heureusement heureusement
monsieur Stéphane bchou merci madame la
Présidente je fais très vite parce que
Madame la rapporteur et Madame la
président me font les gros yeux et si la
question a été posée n'y répondez pas
monsieur le ministre je voulais
simplement savoir si euh vous êtes
favorable à l'arrêt des matchs en cas de
propos discriminant enfin de
comportement pardon discriminant
oui bien sûr permettez-moi l'expression
ça emmerde tout le monde d'arrêter un
match parce moi le premier si j'ai rien
fait je pourquoi il m'arrête le match
mais au bout d'un moment il faut bien
faire des choses et peut-être que ça ça
sensibilisera peut-être les gens qui
étaient au stade et qui n'ont rien fait
quand le voisin criait tenait des pro
racistes peut-être qu'il se dira mais la
prochaine fois je vais dire j'ai pas
envie que le match s'arrête moi
peut-être donc moi je suis favorable
mais nous on avait donner comme consiges
aux arbitres si s'il y a des des des des
termes racisme racistes pardon dans le
dans les tribunes vous arrêtez le match
voilà un joueur c'est carton jaune ou
carton rouge d'accord mais par contre
vous n'hésitez pas à arrêter le
match Monsieur François
pequmal non juste vous dire concernant
les cas de racisme dans le rugby euh
j'ai j'ai pas été voir sur chaque
terrain ce qu'il en était j'ai juste
tapé acte
raciste match de Rugby et vous avez sur
l'année 2023 je vous mens pas au moins
11 12 cas relatés par la presse
c'est-à-dire des des cas qui sont
publics
euh alors à niveau fédéral 2 fédéral 3
fédéral 1 voir ça peut aller au-dessus
ProD2 me semble-t-il qu'il y avait un
cas en pro des de donc voilà c'est c'est
pas une invention c'est que ça existe et
et je suis je vous rejoint quand vous
dites c'est des individus que bon on
peut pas contrôler tout le monde mais il
y a quand même un pour moi un véritable
problème et il y a beaucoup de joueurs
les joueurs qui témoignent de ça s'en
plaignent disent c'est pas la première
fois là je parle seette fois mais il a
peut-être pas parlé la dernière fois
parce que on sait pas comment faire on
sait pas à qui à qui en parler après
concernant les matchs au stade toulousa
c'est vrai que moi quand je suis allé à
Ernest vallon j'ai jamais entendu
d'insulte raciste mais je tiens à vous
rassurer quand je vais au Stadium voir
le TFC non plus et on a un groupe de
supporters qui a pris DESP i ferme sur
le fait que qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir
de d'insulte racisme dans son groupe
donc c'est possible et et je pense que
les fédérations la puissance publique
ont un rôle de d'exemplarité de et
d'action à faire sur le sujet voilà c
juste ça vous parlez des clubs supporter
mais c'est évident que c'est les
premiers
concernés quand un club supporter il
fait venir des licenci et ca il doent
leur dire écoutez ici c'est tolérance
zéro sur le RAC surtout d'ailleurs c'est
le respect de tout c'est les premiers
concernés c'est c'est une évidence je
dis pas qu'ils font rien dans le
football loin de là mais malheureusement
les cas que l'on voit c'est souvent dans
le monde professionnel du football et
Vincent Labrune le premier dit que que
ça les cœur il a il a bien
raison monsieur le ministre il a été
porté à la connaissance de la commission
d'enquête qu'entre 2016 et 2022 la masse
salariale de la FFF avait
considérablement augmenté la FR pardon
entre la saison 2006
2017 et la saison
2022-2023 la masse salariale sportive a
augmenté de 72 % et la masse salariale
administrative de 30 % soit une
augmentation globale de 52 %. les
effectifs quant à eux ont augmenté de 71
% en conséquence de cette augmentation
de masse salariale la FFR présente des
résultats d'exploitation déficitaire
depuis 2017 monsieur grill nous a
informé qu'un déficit d'exploitation de
l'ordre de 16 millions d'euros était à
attendu pour la saison
2022-2023 pouvez-vous revenir sur cette
votre gestion financière de la FFR entre
2017 et 2022 et en particulier un
rapport de l'Inspection générale des
finances et de l'Inspection générale des
affaires culturelles s'est interrogé sur
le niveau de certaines rémunération en
vue de l'équilibre économique fédéral et
du statut d'association à but non
lucratif de la FFR selon la mission la
rémunération de certaines fonctions
administratives serait de 30 à 40 % plus
élevé que la moyenne constatée dans des
entreprises du secteur privé en 2022 3
entraîneurs percevaient ainsi une
rémunération proche ou supérieure à
500000 €
net 500000 € je rajouterai pas net 14
rémunération dépassaient au total les
100000 € pourquoi avoir maintenu des
rémunérations aussi élevé au vu de la
situation financière difficile de la
FFR
il y a deux choses il il y a la masse
salariale sportive et la masse salariale
administrative la masse salariale
administrative depuis 2017-28 elle est
stable elle est stable je voudrais vous
dire que notre directec quand moi je
suis arrivé le directeur général le
directeur général de l'époque de la
Fédération toucher le double je dis bien
le double de ce que nous avons donné à
Laurent gabanini comme directeur général
ENF à l'époque c'était pas Laurent
gabanini puisqueil y avait déjà un
directeur général mais si on compare
salaire de Laurent gabaneni aujourd'hui
c'est la moitié de ce que touchait le
directeur général de l'époque et puis je
vais pas vous faire auense en disant
quand je vois le salaire de certains DG
et notamment au
tennis et notamment au tennis voyez ce
que je veux dire c'était CIN fois plus
que Laurent gabenini CIN fois plus que
ce que touche Laurent gabenini donc moi
je veux bien qu'on me dise truc mais ça
c'est pas vrai d'accord nous il touchit
pas Laur GAB touche pas 35000 € net par
mois hein ça existe pas ça ça n'existe
pas d'accord il a un salaire de 100000
je crois de mémoire avec 20000 de prime
ou ou quelque chose comme ça et je parle
en brute làin je parle en brute d'accord
et je vous répète que c'est la moitié du
dég qui existait avant 2016 et en plus
qui est un ami donc il y a aucun souci
là-dessus lui on a donné le salaire il
l'a pris hein il a pas dit non non vous
me payez trop cher voilà et en plus il
avait 50 ans d'anciennetté il avait fait
un travail considble pour pour le Ruby
français donc c'est pas je critique pas
le salaire du DG précédent mais je tiens
à remettre les choses dans l'ordre quand
même notre DG aujourd'hui c'est pas
35000 € net par mois voilà et pourtant
je crois que la Fédération Française de
Ruby c'est quand même une une des
grandes fédérations deè des choses je
vous dis c'est pour le sportif oui oui
la masse la masse salariale du sportif
mais c'est quoi le sportif c'est
l'encadrement des équipes de France on a
professionnalisé les féminines d'accord
moi quand je suis arrivé on voulait que
les féminines soi performantes et puis
les les entraîneurs étaient
pigistes quand il venaient il touchaient
quand il étaaient pas là il touchaient
pas voilà mais ça peut pas fonctionner
ça alors que les garçons il y avait il y
avait des gens qui étaient rémunérés à
l'année des entraîneurs qui étaient
rémunérés à l'année donc j'ai dit si on
veut développer le Rubby féminin il faut
faire exactement la même chose donc on a
professionnalisé le Rubby féminin on a
salarié l'encadrement des des du Rubby
féminin et puis c'est vrai que on a
étoffé le staff de nos équipes de France
pour retrouver une équipe de France qui
gagne mais je leur disais
l'investissement que l'on doit faire
c'est sur le staff pour que notre équipe
de France regagne et que derrière des
partenaires reviennent mais on n'est pas
passé de de 106 millions d'euros à 133
parce que parce que le président
s'ppelait bien dans la porte ça n'existe
pas ça c'est parce que notre équip de
France elle a regagné et cetera et que
les partenire ont voulu nous accompagner
donc on a investi à partir de 2019 sur
le staff de l'équipe de France oui on a
beaucoup investi et et vous me dites 72
% d'augmentation je vous dirais que
c'est plus je pense que c'est un peu
léger sur la masse salariale sportive
hein je m'entends bien je pense que
c'est plus que 7 % d'augmentation mais
on en est fier et je vous répète que
derrière on on on a on a récupéré ce
qu'il fallait récupérer c'est-à-dire des
des des des partenaires du sponsor comme
comme comme vous voulez l'entendre peu
importe mais ça a été un Paris gagnant
et c'était le seul Paris parce que je le
répète l'équipe de France masculine
c'est 85 % des ressources de la
Fédération française de rugby alors
après on n pas d'accord avecve avec
Monsieur R sur l'exceptionnel ne doit
pas rentrer en compte et cetera mais si
fait pas rentrer un compte exceptionnel
à ce moment-là on aurait moins
redistribué au club mais à partir du
moment où on avait des produits
exceptionnels qui nous permettaient
d'équilibrer parce que vous dites qu'on
est en déficite ce n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas vrai non oui si on enlève si
on enlève l'exceptionnel oui mais nous
l'exceptionnel on on le comptabilisit
fait c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe on
avait un trésorier en charge de cela
Monsieur Martinez il faudrait peut-être
que vous l'entendiez vous l'auditionniez
à lui mais à partir du moment où
l'exceptionnel était là on redistriber
plus au club et on équilibré avec
l'exceptionnel oui et on se disait à
terme il va falloir augmenter le
partenariat des équipes de de France
pour remplacer justement cet
exceptionnel cet exceptionnel étant CVC
qui est un fond d'investissement qui
investit dans les dans les dans les
cination et qui donne grosso modo 13
millions d'euros par an pendant 5
ans donc vous confirmez ou non euh la
position de Monsieur grill comme quoi un
déficit d'exploitation de l'ordre de 16
millions d'euros avec ou sans
l'exceptionnel donc ça ferait 3 millions
d'euros ça va faire 1 an que je suis
parti donc je sais rien sincèrement je
vaux pas pas vous parler de choses que
je connais pas ça ça me ça me surprend
sincèrement parce que bon néanoins c'est
attendu sur la saison 2022
2023 il y a pas eu 16 millions ça été ça
a été l'assemblée générale eu je3 ils
ont pas voté 16 millions de déficit
c'est pas
vrai c'est ce que nous a informé
monsieur grill je répète nous a informé
qu' un déficit d'exploitation de l'ordre
de 16 millions d'euros était attendu
pour la saison
2022-2023 mais ils ont ils ont fait la
ils ont fait ils ont fait l'assemblée
financière je crois le weekend dernier
j'ai pas entendu de ce ce montant là
hein ça me surprend mais bon encore une
fois je vais pas moi ça fait 10 mois que
j'y suis plus je vais pas parler des
choses que je connais pas je vis le
mieux vous convoquez le trésorier de
l'époque il va vous expliquer c'est lui
qui était à la manœuvre en ce qui
concerne les
finances le contrat de délégation conclu
le 30 mars 2022 entre le ministère des
Sports et la FFR ne contient aucune
clause sur la transparence financière de
la Fédération les pratiques de bonne
gestion et la modération salariale alors
que la situation financière de la FFR
était déjà très dégradée est-ce que
cette situation elle fait l'objet
d'échange avec le ministère des Sports
lors de la négociation du contrat de
délégation pas avec moi vous me parlez
quandême de mars 2022 non certainement
avec le directeur général et le
trésorier mais pas avec moi
non en tant que président est-ce que
vous avez assister et participer à des
réunions de travail sur le ce contrat la
rédaction de ce contrat de délégation
avec le ministère des Sports j'ai pas
souvenir est-ce que vous avez lu ce
contrat de délégation avec le ministère
des Sports le contrat délégation il est
reconduit je veux dire c'est pas c'est
pas oui non il y avait des modifications
on est
d'accord c'était le premier contrat de
délégation qui était signé avec le
ministère des sport c'était en mars 2022
avant ça il y avait pas de contrat de
délégation voilà donc est-ce que vous y
avez contribué et oui oui ENF contribué
oui je me rappelle qu'on en a parlé bien
sûr avec avec notre DG notre trésorier
de l'époque et notre secrétaire général
aussi mais non non fait je n'ai pas
participé euh ils avaient encore une
fois les CP les coup des Franches bien
sûr qu'il me tenait au courant des des
des choses mais j'ai mais j'ai je n'y ai
pas participé
non alors est-ce que vous pouvez revenir
sur les sur le déploiement du contrôle
d'honorabilité au sein de la Fédération
Française de Rugby à votre connaissance
combien de personnes ont-elles été
contrôlé en 2021 2022 le nombre exact je
le connais pas mais ça c'est pareil
c'est une chose que y a que la
Fédération Française de RBY qui l'a mis
en place alors après c'est vous savez ce
que c'est c'est il faut il faut croiser
les fichiers ministère de la Justice
ministère de l'Intérieur ministère
ministère des Sports donc ils ont
contrôlé un grand nombre un grand nombre
de d'éducateurs de clubs combien
exactement donc je vous je je vous le
dirai pas mais je suis fier d'avoir
enfin d'avoir que la Fédération
française de rugby a initié ce contrôle
de
nourabilité c'est pas facile hein ce que
sur les retours que j'ai c'est quand
même pas parce que des fois il y a des
retards des institutions
publiques des retards des institutions
publiques je veux dire ils vont moins
vite que nous quoi et c'est normal c'est
tout à fait logique ils ont pas que ça à
faire quoi donc je dis pas qu'il joue
pas le jeu mais on aimerait beaucoup
plus d'après ce que d'après ce que me
disent les gens qui s'en occupent plus
de de de
rapidité de leur
part est-ce que sous votre présidence
vous avez été amené à à effectuer des
signalement au procureur de la
République au titre de l'article
40 pardon
[Musique]
euh ben peut-être que j'oublie mais j'ai
pas
souvenir
sous votre présidence la FFR
c'était-elle déjà constitué parti civile
à des actions pénales afin de licencier
de des afin de soutenir pardon des
licenciés ou ayant porté plainte pour
des faits de racisme ou de violence on
l'a fait voter de mémoire en 2020 à un
comité directeur où on a dit la
Fédération peut effectivement à partir
de maintenant se porter parti civile sur
les sujets que vous évoquez
l'a-t-elle déjà
fait je sais pas je sais
pas c'est fort possible mais là encore
une fois c'est c'estou qui éta en charge
de qui ça de M de M peut-être que
peut-être queon s'est déjà parti civile
sur des sujets qui intéressent notre
commission d'enquête auriez-vous fort de
votre exp bien sûr des recommandations à
nous adresser et au quel cas si vous ne
les avez pas à l'instant peut-être
pourriez-vous nous apporter une
contribution écrite avec plaisir il faut
y réfléchir il faut se poser parce que
je suis comme vous je je supporte pas ni
le racisme ni l'homophobie tout ça
et et moi qui pensais que le sport était
un
secteur privilégié je le dis le rugby
est un secteur privilégié alors je suis
d'accord qu'il y a toujours des actes de
racisme on va pas dire que que ça que ça
n'existe pas et ça existe beaucoup
beaucoup moins que dans d'autres que
dans d'autres sports mais moi je suis
pour des sanctions beaucoup plus fermes
ça c'est clair beaucoup plus ferme et
avec une responsabilité des clubs on
passera pas ça la responsabilité des
clubs les clubs doivent informer les
clubs sans arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt
sans arrêt alors je sais que c'est c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas simple mais il
faut impliquer tout le monde quoi donner
des ordres dans haut c'est bien mais il
faut décentraliser nous par exemple
aujourd'hui quand vous pass c'est un
brevet d'état fait ce qu'on appelle un
brevet d'état il y a une formation à
tout cela parce que souvent les
éducateurs sont démunis il y a une
formation donc ilutut il faut aller au
plus au plus profond du terrain tous les
éducateurs doivent être formés c'est eux
qui c'est eux qui initient c'est eux qui
donnent le le le le l'élan le label
auprès auprès de nos joueurs donc et
puis ce sont eux qui les ont en main ces
joueurs donc là encore une fois ça
comenceel si nos gamins sont bien
éduqués mais mais quand ils grandiront
dans lesestades il y aura plus de
problème c'est pas vrai il y aura plus
de problème or combien je
vois de de de d'amis de pères qui me
disent mon fils joue au foot il y a eu
ça il y a eu C il y a eu ça donc oui
tolérance zéro dès la base tolérance
zéro dès la base c'est c'est ça c'est
une évidence et des sanctions très très
fortes au niveau parce qu'effectivement
l'exemplarité dans le monde
professionnel on est vu donc il faut
être exemplaire mais je veux bien y
réfléchir et vous envoyer des axes de de
solution entre guillemets si on peut
dire auriez-vous des informations
complémentaires à apporter à cette
commission d'enquête qui n'ont pas été
abordé au cours de cette
audition non début
non merci monsieur le ministre nous vous
souhaitons une bonne
journée merci à vous merci de votre
écoute et merci de cette audition pour
cette
audition